if i could have any superpower it would
probably be
teleportation but second to that would
be super speed
in comics perhaps the best known
speedster of all is the flash
this is a character who takes the idea
of speed to insane levels
tapping into the speed force in order to
run at speeds of over 670
million miles per hour what's really
cool about the flash is that he's not
just fast when it comes to running
he can also read super fast build super
fast and react
super fast he probably has super fast
broadband
his brain is capable of processing
visual imagery in less than an
ato second which would be a requirement
for anyone moving that fast
so if we really want to train like barry
allen we're gonna need to
supercharge our entire bodies we may not
be able to travel through time
but we could train to move think and
react faster
than everyone else like all of these out
there approaches to training
this is easier than it sounds because
very few people train the stuff at all
advantage us so let's start with moving
faster
the good news this is something that has
been plenty researched already
one of the coolest methods for training
running speed or getting faster at
anything
which i've touched on previously is to
use something called overspeed training
the idea here is that you'll use any
method you can to go faster than you
normally would
while moving the most obvious example is
when running you might run down a hill
or some people will even tow themselves
behind cars
this is highly effective because it
forces your nervous system to adapt
you're learning the movement patterns
and the recruitment necessary to reach
those speeds
so that your body remembers how to go
faster and can eventually do it on its
own in future
the problem with this kind of training
it can be a fast track to injury
a slightly different approach then is to
simply train
as fast as you can or faster even than
you intend to move in practice
with fast intent the same is true when
punching when throwing
when doing push-ups so many of us have a
tendency to actually slow the movements
down while training
to be slow and deliberate and to just go
through the motions if you want to get
faster then you need to attack the
movement
but it will also help to develop a
higher ratio of fast
and super fast twitch muscle fibers note
that this is specific to the area you're
training
sprinting is great if you want to run
faster but if you want to be faster
then you need to practice moving all of
your limbs more quickly and explosively
this is why plyometric and ballistic
exercises can be particularly effective
for increasing speed
the aim is to move as quickly and
explosively as possible and this is
enhanced if you do it against
sub-maximal resistance
note that i say sub-maximal if you
attempt to lift your one rep maximum
through a controlled range of motion
as in a bench press or a squat then
you'll be forced to slow down your
cadence
thus making the movement less explosive
less quick
the rule of 90 suggests the optimum
amount of weight to use is
90 of your one rep maximum if you want
to build strength
seeing as many people equate strength to
force production and force production to
velocity
it follows that developing max strength
this way will make you super fast
so does this rule out kettlebells and
calisthenics for optimal speed and
explosiveness
not so fast because there are other
schools of thought that suggest 30
percent of your on rep maximum
is the point where many exercises are
recorded generating
peak power output it's a kind of
goldilocks zone
many powerlifters will likewise drop
their lows to around 70 percent
in order to apply a technique called
compensatory acceleration
here they're using the same effort and
explosiveness as though they were moving
one rep max
but the lighter load means that they'll
explode through the movement more
quickly
bruce lee used a similar speed training
technique for his training
attempting to finish the same workout in
the shortest possible time
by moving the weights faster and most
people would probably agree that
bruce was pretty quick explosive
movements that rely on compensatory
acceleration and explosions of power
are better at developing rate of force
production
even if you're a power lifter who lifts
extremely heavy chances are you're still
using predominantly
type 2a twitch muscle fiber because the
movement is too slow
but you will actually decrease the
number of superfast 2x fibers
which are used in things like olympic
lifting and sprinting
many olympic lifts are actually
described as being almost plyometric
they rely on a stretch shortening cycle
and they're explosive
almost like a throw like a medicine ball
slam in one study it was found that
sedentary individuals
had muscles comprised of 12 percent type
2x fiber
whereas powerlifters had only one
percent that said the powerlifting group
had a significantly higher proportion of
intermediate type 2a fibers
remember we're not training for a
specific event but rather to simply be
quicker to that end we need a more
varied selection of movements that
includes
level changes direction changes rotation
and more
you can't train these movements with 100
of your one rep max because that would
lead to injury
but don't feel wed to the number 30
either when you look at the research it
turns out that max power output
actually varies significantly from one
exercise to another
some of these movements like the hang
power clean peak at 80 percent
others like the split jump squat appear
to peak at 30 to 60 percent
your job is to listen to your own body
and to try and feel when you're moving
with maximum explosiveness
and force versus slowly grinding through
reps
or harming your technique and stability
intramuscular coordination has as much
to do with fast and efficient movement
as does muscle fiber recruitment you
should focus on stiffening the core
and driving through the glutes so as to
maintain that truly athletic performance
so how might we apply this to running
like the flash we can practice
over speed training against resistance
with movements like the sled push
prowler sprints running on sand running
uphill or running with a parachute
or you could actually buy sand
simulation shoes
we can also use a number of speed drills
to practice overspeed training and
explosiveness
without needing space to sprint examples
include marching a's and high knees
all of these will slightly change the
gate though so this needs to be done in
conjunction
with regular sprinting the biomechanics
of sprinting vary between the
acceleration phase
takeoff and the maintenance phase or
gliding phase where that high speed is
sustained
in the acceleration phase the athlete
leans further forwards
so their foot is behind their center of
mass and this also allows gravity to
help them achieve top speed quickly
there's an emphasis on pushing through
the back leg to launch off the ground
as they approach the gliding phase they
move into a more upright posture so the
foot lands beneath the hip
increasing stride length while
attempting not to drastically reduce
stride frequency
and relaxing the upper body low
shoulders and jelly jaw
this is similar to the way a martial
artist develops speed by driving through
the floor
then loosening the body to move like a
whip to build more power and speed then
we need to focus on generating maximum
power for minimal ground contact time
this is also where drills like marching
a's and high knees become extremely
useful
we should also focus on stabilizing the
hips and knees and learning to drive
power off of one leg
strengthening the core is always
beneficial for speed as we have seen
before
another example of this is when
sprinting at which point anti-extension
movements can help to keep the body
sufficiently upright during the gliding
phase
of the sprint keep in mind that while
all these things are important
individual differences also play a huge
role case in point
usain bolt reportedly has slight
scoliosis
which means that one leg is slightly
longer than the other this results in an
uneven stride with significantly more
power
13 to be precise generated on one side
than the other
usain is about the closest thing we have
to real world flash
so don't sweat the small stuff if we
really want to become blindingly fast
though then it is just as important that
we learn to react and think quickly
to this end we need to speed up our
reaction times but again things aren't
so straightforward
in order to react to something like a
punch being thrown we need to first
process the visual information coming
into us the fastest nerve impulses
travel around 250 miles an hour
meaning it will take around 13
milliseconds for that information to
reach the brain
it then takes a further 0.3 seconds for
a signal to reach your hand from your
brain
but before even this happens your brain
needs to collect information from
elsewhere in your body
otherwise there'd be a kind of lag all
this information is collected into a
single image of one moment
author of the book felt time the
psychology of how he perceived time
mark whitman explains the difference
between the functional moment
the experienced moment and the
remembered moment stored in our working
memory
the perceptual moment varies from one
sense to another
and can be measured for example by
clicking in the right and left ear
and then measuring the amount of time
required to separate those clicks
in order for them to appear as
sequential rather than simultaneous
we can react to this kind of input
unconsciously but we won't necessarily
be consciously aware of the difference
there are many scenarios in sports where
an athlete won't have enough time to
react to an event consciously
in this situation they must rely on rote
repetition that has ensured their
reactions are instinctual
this rope repetition also strengthens
the pathways in the brain
via myelination and other processes
thereby allowing the signal to travel
faster
as bruce lee says it hits all by itself
the experienced moment however is a
little longer this is closer to two to
three seconds
and this is the amount of time at which
the passage of time becomes something we
are consciously aware of
this is what gives us the window of
opportunity to make a logical decision
about the best course of action
and we know this amount of time can
slightly change in response to events
around us
as in the way time appears to slow to a
crawl in a life or death situation
while the precise mechanisms for this
process aren't fully understood and it
may even be illusory
a trick caused by the way memory is
encoded it's generally agreed that
increased focus and arousal in the brain
could help to encourage this increased
awareness entering a flow state may help
to accomplish this too
which is something i've made plenty of
videos about in the past
there are things we can do to marginally
increase these reaction times too
supplementation is one example one of
the most interesting examples
is combining lutein and zeaxanthin this
combination has been shown in studies to
increase visual processing speeds
and improve visual motor reaction times
by as much as 10 percent
for the reasons described you're not
going to feel 10 faster
but that's still pretty awesome engaging
the peripheral vision can help too
not only does this allow you to utilize
receptors at the edge of the eye that
actually
reach the brain quicker but it also
gives you a broader frame of reference
and allows you to bring in more
information
it may even help to accomplish that
state of flow and if you want to make
better decisions in those split seconds
of perceived
time it turns out that this is something
that can be practiced and improved as
well
both playing a musical instrument and
playing first person shooting games
have been shown to speed up decision
making with no apparent drop-off in
accuracy
there's much more to moving and thinking
quickly and i could easily expand this
into an entire series
it's certainly something i'll be
addressing again in future but suffice
to say that if you want to move by the
flash
stop going through the motions and start
moving quickly efficiently and
powerfully
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share it around
that helped me out immensely let me know
what other characters from popular
culture you'd like me to address
and look at the training of and let me
know if you have any other tips on how
to move and think more quickly share
those in the comments down below
if you like the idea of training for
more than just strength or endurance
then you'll probably enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training
that looks at how to train the body and
the mind in a comprehensive manner
and using some rather unique techniques
there's a discount on right now whilst
we're all in lockdown and you can find
the link in the description down below
subscribe if you want more like this of
course and thanks a ton for watching
i'll see you next time bye for now